>> This is that painful point
in every Dolphins season
used around mid November
when all hope is lost and I turn
to the NFL official oddsmaker
A for four or five.
>> Years. Daniel what is mine.
Thanks for having me on Doug.
>> Seen being is about this
whole Super Bowl bullshit
and how the teams will midseason
and all those of us who.
Let's keep it real here.
Well we already know who's going
to win the Super Bowl
is going to be in New England
might give you a smokescreen
with New England
and the Rams and New England
in mother in New Orleans.
But. New England's going
to win the Super Bowl
and that's my locker all week.
The Patriots.
>> That flew 16 year
run is over there
goes to Aaron Hernandez
is going to curse
that franchise.